itadoriuji is a
fantastic character not because he's the
vessel for sukuna the king of curses
but because of how human he is despite
his superhuman strength
enhanced reflexes and his innate ability
to contain one of the biggest threats to
humanity
he has one defining characteristic that
is often overlooked
his selfish selflessness while in many
ways itadore yuji appears to be your
typical shonen protagonist
there is a reason why the story
surrounding him has gotten as popular
and enjoyable as it has
and that's because itadori is one of the
most relatable characters i've ever come
across
he's charming friendly and easy going
but he's also one of the loneliest
on the surface itadori is your typical
shonen protagonist high school student
as many quote-unquote straightforward
protagonists he gets portrayed as kind
adventurous and
somewhat simple academically speaking
however in his case this is a little bit
less extreme as with some of the more
idealistic characters such as luffy
naruto asta while these characters
represent certain ideals
expressed on a grander scale that the
audience can then look up to
i think itadori embodies a much more
down-to-earth and genuine version of
these traits with his one and only goal
being to live by the last words of his
grandfather
and that makes him less of an
unattainable ideal
and more of a relatable equal a big
portion of itadore's charm comes from
him being overall just a regular guy who
seems pretty fun to spend an afternoon
with this
also makes him a much more flexible and
malleable character with the ability to
look past animosity
and make friends of enemies we can see
this in his relationship with jumpe
and again later with his instant besto
friendo
todo and yet akutami the author of
jujutsu kaisen
doesn't shove it into our face that yuji
is a nice person
by having him deliver major speeches or
having other characters talk about what
a great guy he actually is
instead he leaves it for us to decide
what we think of him
in my mind he's pretty likable and
extroverted but
not overly so and at times there is a
certain awkwardness in his interactions
with his peers
his strong points are of course his
superhuman strength and his attitude for
jujutsu
but i think the actual power of his
comes from his extreme
altruism and his ability to act on
behalf of others
and yet as any good protagonist despite
itadore being an
awesome guy all around he still of
course
also has his weaknesses one thing that
isn't quite obvious from the start i
think
is that itadori actually has a really
strong sense of emptiness and loneliness
now since we know very little about his
past it's actually quite hard to tell
why this is the case despite his very
charismatic and extroverted nature
there is an answer to this question
however i believe the
fundamental flaw in itadore's
personality is actually the very same as
his strength
his altruism itadore yuji just like
luffy and the others
is an absolute genius when it comes to
people he's
extremely good at understanding them
what they're about
what drives them and how to handle them
but while he's
excellent at reading others he's
terrible at understanding himself
when we first meet itadori he has no
path
no drive and no meaningful relationships
in his life
except for his grumpy grandpa at school
even though he's absolutely notorious
for his physique he
doesn't have any real friends yes he
calls the two members of the occultist
club his friends but
they literally know nothing about him
also itadori only entered the club so he
could leave school early and visit his
grandpa in the first place
and so when he ultimately loses his
grandfather the
only person he was ever close to he
falls into grief and a very deep
sense of loneliness with no friends and
no purpose and suddenly presented with
the world of jiu-jitsu
itadori latches onto his grandfather's
dying wish
help others and die surrounded by
friends
and he's actually fully aware that this
is probably not the right thing to do
as he calls it his own curse
[Music]
[Music]
but with nothing else to hold on to it
thus
becomes his drive as a result we see
tadouri risking his life on a regular
basis
sometimes quite unnecessarily more than
once he just
rushes into situations with no regard
for his own health or life
and even though he admits that he's
scared of death he seems
way too eager to sacrifice himself for
others and thus try and give his life
meaning and purpose
this in my opinion quite toxic mindset
can be summarized like this
i must save and help others but i can't
receive help from anyone else
i must do everything myself this mindset
by the way
is also shared by itadore's counterpart
ghetto and so while itadore's altruism
is very much
real it is so extreme that ironically
enough
it starts to become selfish he wants to
do anything and
everything for others so that in return
he gets the validation and the
permission
to live his life the problem is when you
build relationships based on this
premise they
inevitably fall apart sooner or later
just as itadoris do
relationships are built on mutual
respect trust and sacrifice
and the buzzword here being mutual in
fulfilling his grandfather's wish and
his ultimate goal
itadori acts on his own and i think that
in searching for his purpose and wanting
to be needed
yuji enters the lives of other people
probably unconsciously
assuming that he can save them for
instance he does so for fushigoro and
jinpe but
very much disliked it himself when toto
does the very same thing to him at first
in short itadori looks for purpose and
validation
by making everything in his life about
others
therefore his character arc is all about
learning to form
real relationships built on mutual
feelings
mutual hardship mutual forgiveness and
mutual
sacrifice i think itadori's character
needs to find a real purpose
not to die for others but one that's
actually worth staying alive for
forming bonds that give meaning to his
life and make him appreciate
how precious it actually is the central
theme and moral argument of jiu-jitsu
kaisen is the question
what constitutes a good life that is
worth living andy tadouri as the main
protagonist
is starting his arc with a very
dangerous and self-destructive answer to
this question
[Music]
and yet the skill with which akutami is
able to expertly portray this weakness
as an underlying part of itadore's
personality
and only revealing it in tiny bits shows
his real skills as a writer
and makes itadori immediately immensely
relatable as a character
thus itadoriyuji is an extremely human
and realistic take on the comment shown
in tropes
that actually come very close to
togashi's way of writing however i
personally think that itadori's arc will
most likely come closer to that of kilua
from darkness into light
rather than guns fall into darkness and
i would even go as far as to say that
akutami's characters are even a tad more
complex and realistic in their design
satorugojo itadori's mentor comes to
mind here as well who is
eccentric intimidating funny and
so much more at the same time
these deep personalities complex
motivations and relationships
all combined with the gory and
fantasy-like elements set in a real
world setting have created a fantastic
story world for us to explore
and speaking of gojo you can watch his
analysis
right here thanks so much for watching
peace